[Música]
nada parece calmar la atención en las
calles de perú cientos de manifestantes
de ambos bandos políticos volvieron a
las calles los seguidores del castillo
piden que su candidato sea declarado
ganador los ecos insisten en las
denuncias de un supuesto fraude
nacional de elecciones por
y no respetar nuestro gato sin embargo
en un revés para la candidata de fuerza
popular la misión de observación de la
organización de estados américanos se
pronunció sobre la transparencia de los
comicios la misión de observación
electoral de la oea ha expresado que
observó un proceso electoral positivo en
el que se registraron mejoras
sustantivas entre la primera y segunda
vuelta asimismo que la misión no ha
detectado graves irregularidades el
jurado nacional electoral tuvo la
intención de dar una prórroga
extraordinaria a la impugnación de actas
lo que desató una oleada de críticas
especialmente por parte del partido de
castillo que denunció un intento de
golpe y está planteando que hay un
fraude sistemático
situación totalmente falsa y además
peligrosa la palabra sistemático porque
está pretendiendo engañar al pueblo
peruano que perú libre sus personeros
han actuado de manera delincuencial
sistemáticamente para poder concretar el
fraude sin embargo más tarde el jurado
nacional electoral decidió revisar su
decisión y dejar sin efecto la
ampliación del plazo para recibir
nulidad es haciendo señalamientos hasta
ahora infundados de fraude la candidata
keiko fujimori busca que unas 800 actas
es decir unos 200.000 votos
especialmente de las zonas rurales sean
anuladas con el 100% de las actas
procesadas unos 52 mil votos separan a
los candidatos con un conteo que
favorece al candidato socialista sin
embargo pero sigue sin conocer
oficialmente el nombre de su próximo
mandatario